[Music]
here we are here we are thank you for
being on the show you're welcome thanks
for having a
show let's start that way how many times
have you listened to the show I think
you have you have really yeah I think
I've told you each time I thought you
just did it once and that's when I was
on somebody else's show cuz you want to
see if we could still be married no I've
listened to three of yours really yeah
the AMA
because I want to know what you're
saying oh about you yeah if you're
talking about other
people I don't listen yeah you might be
talking about me then I think I talk
about you a lot probably and that's the
other reason I don't listen what I don't
know I don't have to be mad about so one
of the questions we get almost um on a
daily or weekly basis is something that
at the beginning I thought you might be
sending in over and over and over again
because it's our house and so but I
don't think it is I think it's something
that is just pervasive
so how have you managed how do you
manage to live with and be married and
most of the time love all the time love
most of the time like um somebody with
ADHD somebody who struggles with anxiety
or OCD some of these some of these big
dragon labels how have you learned to
create a life with it with that within
that by the way we have not prepped this
I am not an expert on any of those
things you're an expert on loving me
said I an expert on you so you're the
only person that I've been married
to so said how have you how have you
stayed in love with me I'm going to I'm
going to keep it to what's it like to
live with you and love
you with the Tendencies You may have
that may may be generalizable but I
don't know
I think the biggest one is a change in
expectations so I may think that
tidiness is a priority among all adults
and that turns out not to be true so
where I would prefer people are coming
over let's tidy up the
house I prefer like people are coming
over let's be on let's be on the front
porch or be mowing the front yard yes
because if they're coming at 6 I can
start mowing at 5:30 and duh plenty of
time so so shifting expectations I'm not
going to have a tidy house and that is
just the life that I chose but I never
have a boring house either so so I I in
my head remember it approximately 10
years ago is that there was like a
distinct change and then probably 5
years ago when we were leaving Texas and
moving here here and things were just a
mess that there was like yet another
change and I felt the air leave the
house in a good way like there was the
pressure that I lived to that was me
giving up is that is that is yeah was
that like I quit um but there was like a
distinct shift and in an odd way and you
can tell me if I'm wrong I felt like
without that constant I'm not doing this
right I then I have felt space to then
start to slowly quietly and my way
towards like being a little more tidy
sometimes yeah yeah that's true and some
of it is letting go of expectations
other people like when you name those
markers 5 years ago 10 years ago that's
also when as an adult I've quit being so
consumed with what other people think of
me or think of us and so some of the the
buildup was what are other people going
to think if John's still in the shower
when they get to our house or or what
are our parents going to think if they
show up in the house is a wreck or the
front yard has weird things piled and
stacked here and there um and just
coming to a place where I don't know
this is how we live we live in chaos
and welcome welcome to yeah rather than
putting out some sort of trying to
pretend that we live a tidy life when we
don't that sounds
like an uncomfort
response that I think is pretty powerful
so tell me if I'm wrong here what I'm
hearing you say
is when
you I'm going say do the work but that
doesn't necessarily mean that but when
you started doing the work on you
MH and we stopped butting heads on it's
got to look like this like but I've got
so much going on here right and then it
was almost like
when yeah when you
went
and you can call giving up I would say
making peace with the other side of it
is
um I don't know I just felt there was
such more space in the house for joy and
peace and laughter which then for me
calms everything down and then it's like
oh I see that pile I'm not going to get
to it but I see it now I've never seen
that pile before cuz I was too busy
trying to like walk on a on a rope that
I didn't understand
yeah and I think it also when you think
of those markers 5 years ago 10 years
ago 5 years ago when we moved here I
stopped working in schools 10 years ago
I stopped working
full-time if we were both still leaving
the house one of us on time and getting
home in the evening and then coming in
and like dinner's got to be ready and
then we got to start the next day and we
need the decks cleared to start a whole
new day if we were both doing that I
don't know that I could have come to
that place
of whatever you called it to peace with
it what do it I've the story I've told
myself over time is especially in the
last couple years as it's become
incredibly important for me something
I'm trying to work on hard is being on
time
and it was when I it was when I started
working here and I wasn't the leader of
an organization and when you're a leader
of an organization you kind of live in a
bubble because everybody just morph to
what your
weirdness here there was like some
really poignant like you're being very
disrespect respectful of all of the
people in this room or and you like you
see here there's a whole team of people
and if I roll in 6 minutes late it's
like oh and I'm thinking I'll get the
show done Show's going to be fun I've
already checked the calls I know what
it's coming I'll be all right but
there's still five or 10 or 15 people
sitting there waiting and how have you
navigated just that honest feeling like
like sitting in the car waiting for us
to go to church or like we're going to
leave at 5:30 for our date because we're
nerds and it's 6:15 and I'm getting out
of the shower
like like talk through that
like feeling of
disrespect oh that's another one there
there's two parts to it and and really
though it overlaps with what I was
saying before some of it is expectation
I just don't expect to be on time for
things um I think our church Community
does not expect us to be on
time our kids don't expect you to be on
time I know and we try to make
adjustments like telling you it's really
7:15 is when we need to leave when three
of the four of us know it's really 7:30
but this is gives us a better shot at
leaving on time um so some of it's
giving up like just like oh we're just
not going to be and then some of it is
letting go of if somebody wants to give
us a dirty look when we walk in late to
church well okay and just not being as
concerned about that um and then the
other thing again because I'm not
working full-time I work from home I
work for myself so you're not causing me
to be late for something so it's less
the stakes are lower so I can give you
more room to be late and it
doesn't I don't know so when I talk to
people out on the road they say it must
be so fun like just this picture of like
y'all's house sounds so
fun I know there's another side of fun
which is exhausting exhausting so um how
do you navigate that because I know that
I someone who like is working hard but
man time is hard for me uh I I'm really
I'm called a few experts like cuz I'm at
the the end of my rope on like clutter
like and we're not hoarders but I got
soone just stuff I just got Stu we not
but I just got clutter and um but I'm
I'm at this weird place like I'm I'm out
of Tricks right the tricks that I use to
like cut weight the tricks I use to
exercise the tricks I use for nutrition
don't work for that for some reason so
there's the other side of that like oh
my gosh it must be so fun and those are
hilarious and our daughter's a a
hurricane she's hilar ious and our son
is so witty and funny and there always
cracking jokes and there's the other
side of that which is just exhausting
how do you navigate that I take naps and
I go to bed
early
um what else do I have I check out yeah
yeah again it's that same bucket of just
letting go you didn't trick me you
weren't on time while we were dating and
had all your stuff together then so I
knew what I was getting um you know I
used to say it's a good thing you're
cute yeah that's the same thing I said
about our kids um but as I'm getting
older I can't lean on that anymore you
better see figure something out I know
um what about this uh folks who struggle
mightily with anxiety and ADHD um and
even into depression often have really
negative self-image cuz it's like I know
you know what I mean I know that I'm not
on time I know that and I worked really
hard to get my breakfast done I worked
really hard to be present with the kids
in my head I'm like you're going to
spend some time with your wife you're
going to make sure you eat a healthy
breakfast you're going to do all these
things and then it's like the freaking
clock won't stop spinning and so and
that's just one thing like there's
moments of of Lucidity where I see like
this house is a disaster and 97.8% of it
is me and the rest of it is a middle
school boy right it's embarrassing like
it's it's shameful how do you navigate
loving somebody who like doesn't always
share that same love for themselves I
don't know I don't know that
I'm doing it
well um I I guess part of it is loving
you and
so like beyond that I don't know what to
do but I can love you without loving
your behaviors and be in relationship
with you I think maybe this is another
switch that has happened is to stop
trying to be in relationship with your
behaviors and your mess and what that is
and just kind of jump over that and be
in relationship with you the person who
means well and is always kind and has a
million other things that I love and if
you know if I stacked those up because I
love lists if I stacked those up on list
that way outweighs the fact that you
leave your stuff
everywhere um everywhere I get it's
worth the trade I guess if this if this
is the trade to make like well you get
this great guy but he's a mess well yeah
I'm gonna I'll deal with the
mess I would say the greatest gift you
bring me is like a
constant stop pulling on your shirt you
don't look unattractive and stop you can
leave that stuff there I'd rather you
come to bed or like there's some moments
that I've felt especially over the last
four or five years where it's been very
much a focus
on I'm like you just mentioned like
you're good with me and for some weird
reason that has slowly begun to let the
shame smoke out and almost like a
release valve then I can't describe it
other
than people with ADHD and OCD and
anxiety are so frustrating to be in
relationship with because it's so like
why do you have to be like that and it's
like I don't know right it's like we
were talking with our kids the other day
like one of our children it was like
does that feel good and they were like
no it doesn't feel even good and but in
a strange
way you leaning into
that instead of like setting a marker
over here and like you will meet this
expectation and for me and my body
response to that is like that's my dad
whose expectation I'm still trying to
meet that's my teacher who that one time
or the football coach I'm still instead
of that it's like moving all the way up
here and be like I will love you to
spite the piles I'll end for some reason
I start to see them and be like all
right I'm going get that I'm goingon to
get that taken care of I do know in our
in our like our kitchen area I dropped
that guitar and all that stuff right
there in that huge pile I know that I
know it's there but I saw it and even
when I was leaving this morning I had to
make a choice between the pile and
timeliness and I chose being on time but
I did see it which is huge did you
choose being on time cuz you knew I was
going to get here first no um I chose
being on time because I had announcement
to makeing frun of a thousand people so
I had to be there on that stage when the
time came but but it's it's there's been
times I've sent a text message like move
me to third because I'm coming in hot
four minutes later or whatever um but
some of that's just
being I know it's self-reinforcing over
the last six no probably over the last
year as I've tried to really work hard
especially at work on getting on time
there's like a like the there's more
peace like I feel better right being
here early and I can prepare and people
aren't stressed and people aren't
frustrated and trying to bite their
tongue around me or like Kelly who's not
biting her tongue and just letting it
fly right there's just a pieace right um
and I'm slowly leaning into that which I
like but yeah so what I hear you saying
is me not shaming you helps you feel
less shamed but I don't even T but I
don't think I don't there's been some of
that both and we've both lobed that
grenad at each other over the course of
21 years but I think it's less that I
think it's more there was just a um like
there's a pair of glasses you wore that
was this is the way this is supposed to
be
and I kept saying but it didn't have to
be we could just stay up till midnight
and go to this punk rock show that
doesn't start till 1:00 a.m. and you're
like I know but for the next six days it
will take us that long to get back and
I'm like I know but it'd be so fun right
now all of this is problems for future
John and Sheila but right now now and so
there's just that talk we and we've
laughed about over 20 years like thank
God that I have you
because I I literally don't know where I
would be and the other side of it is
like you never would have been to a punk
rock show that is true I do want to
point out two things I'll answer but
first because I'm here part of the issue
with your timeliness is that you just
mentioned we're going to be out till
midnight for a punk rock show that start
starts at 1:00
a.m. and there's where the problem
starts in response those are the same
time
basically anything after 11: and before
2: a.m. that's about the same time it
responds so some of it has also been I
quit picking up after you so there was
the it has to be this way so I'm just
going to do it all myself I since you
don't care about having a tidy house and
I do I'm just going to clean up all your
mess for you felt thater then there was
that resentment yeah super rage
cleaning now can be buing in from work
like hey and it would just be wow
because you hadn't noticed the piles to
begin with so you also didn't notice the
absence of piles it was just like hey
guys what youve been doing all day yeah
and so that that was definitely a source
of built up resentment um same with like
John you probably you're supposed to be
at work in 30 minutes and you're my
haven't haven't showered or anything so
letting go of that and like you want to
have piles or even if you don't want
them you made piles okay we're just
going to live in a pile house and I'm
going to carve out a little corner that
I'm going to keep tidy and no one else
is allowed in my
corner